after over a decade from its original
xbox 360 release the beloved alan wake
has been remastered the new version is
available on all modern platforms and
while it's not a complete remake of the
game it does come with a pretty
substantial host of visual upgrades most
notably in the character models
specifically alan wake who looks
substantially different they went ahead
and did a new face model which more
resembles the actor who betrays him it
can be a bit jarring for those of us who
grew up with the game but i do think the
change is ultimately a better one as
alan wake has much better expressions
and facial detail please enjoy this
comparison between the original xbox 360
version and the remastered running on
the ps5 and of course if you enjoyed
this video please give a like and sub it
really helps us out a lot
[Music]
stephen king once wrote that nightmares
exist outside of logic and there's
little fun to be had in explanations
they're antithetical to the poetry of
fear
in a horror story the victim keeps
asking why but there can be no
explanation and there shouldn't be one
the unanswered mystery is what stays
with us the longest and is what we'll
remember in the end
my name is alan wake
i'm a writer
[Music]
i've always had a vivid imagination
but this dream unsettled me it was wild
and dark and weird even by my standards
so yes
it began with a dream
following a typical nightmare pattern i
was late
desperately trying to reach my
destination a lighthouse for some urgent
reason i couldn't remember i've been
driving too fast down a coastal road to
get there
[Applause]
i'd seen the hitchhiker too late
he was dead
i was convinced they put me in jail and
i would never see alice again
oh no
stop
no don't die
no
i can keep this up
baby just another nightmare
everything's fine he dosed off right
anything more than dozed off would be
news for everyone
cheer up handsome we're here
[Music]
sure i'll even give you a title for the
shot a city boy moments before he got
eaten by a pair
don't pretend i don't recognize a famous
writer such as yourself mr
a pleasure
i'm an avid reader myself i hope this
isn't too presumptuous of me but i'm the
night host of the local radio station
any chance i can get an interview
i'll go fill her up while you get the
key i'll pick you up here and say 15
minutes sure
alan
thank you for coming here with me i love
you too go on i'll promise to behave
[Music]
i'd forgotten there were still places
like this
towns where everybody knew everybody
welcome to the oh dear diner hi i was
wondering if you could help me i'm
looking forward awake alan wake oh god i
am your biggest fan i know people say
that all the time but i really am i'm
glad to hear that
rose rose i'm looking for mr stuckey
carl stuckey
carl of course mr wake
he must have gone to visit the restroom
can't believe it i've got all your books
i got the cutout from the bookstore when
they took it out of the window
and to keep it here well okay
good for you
drive it
mission accomplished the key and the
directions my hero
i got some flashlights just in case
hey wait
this is wake
yeah
keys
wow
it's gorgeous alan
it's something all right
don't worry honey i'll get you inside
safe and sound before it gets dark and
i've got the flashlight
it's dark in there we need lights can
you figure out how to get the power on
honey
hello anyone here
you